[Music]
okay guys i am so
grateful for everyone who sent me
flowers do not judge me on the song in
the bathroom
my kids
but oh
my god kim kardashian's kids totally
trolled her on her birthday forcing her
to listen to her 2011 track jam turn it
up on repeat
having kids is just there's no way to
describe it but it's a lot the kkw
beauty founder turned 41 years old on
thursday and documented the day on
social media including all the flowers
she received from her friends and family
[Music]
i can't wait to read all of these cards
[Music]
and there is more
yeah and if you listen closely you'll
hear the track that kim recorded back in
the day blasting in the background
courtesy of her kids
okay guys can we change some music
please
[Music]
just in case you forgot kim briefly
attempted a career in music
[Music]
i wanna give it a nine and i'm not
kidding i really love it
in 2019 when the reality star and her
sisters courtney and khloe kardashian
sat down with andy cohen on watch what
happens live kim said she didn't regret
it that's like the one thing i'm like i
can't believe i did that but then i
talked to the dream about it who like
wrote it and we were like you know what
we donated our money to a cancer
organization he's like did you have fun
and i was like yeah he had fun and he's
like okay then stop like being so hard
on yourself about making a lame decision
right i don't think she was like trying
to be mariah carey with this song right
i think for what it was it was great but
back to kim's birthday you just gotta
roll with it later in the night kim's
kids had a dance party to ladies night
song from kim's recent stint hosting
saturday night live i'm in the vip and
the music is pumping i get up on the
couch and
this is what they're making me watch
[Music]
yeah and kim's daughter north seemed to
love it
[Music]
the birthday girl's friend and publicist
tracy romulus paid tribute to her pal on
her big day posting this behind the
scenes video of kim recording the track
for snl look like trish woke up
talked to trish
why are you worried about me and kim who
is studying to be a lawyer posted a clip
to her own insta story of a very special
flower arrangement she received look at
what alex wang sent me
it's like a gavel
how pretty right like a court
like thing that you hit
like
order in the courtney like that thing
of course that's a reference to kim's
skit on sabelle doing her best
impression of her sister courtney order
order order in the courtney
i'm good at this
kim's famous fam sent her tons of love
on her special day posting a plethora of
throwback pics i don't have that good of
content on kim and on thursday chloe
opened up about kardashian jenner
birthdays on the ellen degeneres show i
like to post really
sappy long emotional like tributes to
them and just because you know one day
if i'm not here i want them to always
remember and that's just what she did
for kim captioning a series of childhood
photos alongside a message that read in
part quote i pray that every wish you
have comes true you are so deserving of
everything beautiful in this world i
love you beyond description in every
lifetime before and later i love you
until the end of time i love you
[Music]
you